in March I was lucky enough to be able
to visit the Pixar Animation Studios in
San Francisco which was not gonna lie
probably one of the best experiences of
my life what can I say I'm a bit of a
Pixar fanboy Pixar by the way being the
company that's made all of the Toy Story
films Finding Nemo The Incredibles up
wall-e for me as someone who in the eyes
of many is still just a kid and who
still doesn't really know what they want
to do with their life going to Pixar was
a pretty inspiring trip for me learning
about Pixar I found myself relating to
the ethics that the company has and for
example they seem to be quite grounded
as a company hello I'm Lee Unkrich
director of Toy Story 3 and I'm sitting
next to charlie is the you visited the
studio so you know we're totally away
from Hollywood we're up in Northern
California I get all the joy of making
movies all day every day but then I can
go home to my kids and my neighbors and
I you know nobody cares who I am and and
you know we we all live very very normal
lives as a video blogger one of the
things that's important to me is just to
kind of be you know a real person a real
normal person who just sits at home in
his bedroom talking to his camera and I
really appreciate that the Pixar
employees kind of share that want to
just be normal people that feeling of
kind of being grounded in a real normal
life infuses itself into the movies
Pixar films have this universal appeal
as well and I really appreciate the fact
that they don't try and add ear to any
kind of particular audience there's
something good about it especially you
it's like you can just completely
utterly focus on what you're making and
you know maybe you're thinking a little
bit about what people will think but if
you're doing something good you're not
worrying about that too much you're just
kind of making what you want to make we
really just try to make stuff selfishly
that we want to see I just try my best
to make videos that I myself would want
to watch and I think that results in me
caring more about the videos that I make
and hopefully making them as good as I
possibly can I mean I don't know if you
read comments about anything you put
okay yeah so you know you get good and
you get bad and you said hopefully
there's a there's a trend towards the
good I'm so grateful to stumble across
YouTube so you have these amazing
opportunities like going to pick Sark on
my way with the opportunities that I'd
found myself with I was really having
trouble trying to work out what enough I
wanted to do with my time and I think it
was only as a result of going to pick
something really realized that the most
important thing to me
is YouTube I love making things you know
and it's only with YouTube that I can
really have the freedom to make whatever
I want to make without having to answer
to anyone else and it was only with that
that I realized that the YouTube is what
I want to dedicate my time to so I would
just wanted to tell you that I guess I
want to dedicate my time to you or
apologies of you expecting something or
comedy written but I really just wanted
to talk today thank you for putting up
with me that is all however if you have
a little bit more time and you want to
play a game I recently made an episode
of truth or fail all about Pixar which
you can play straight off the outro so
keep watching if you want to play that
and if not doesn't matter you can do
whatever you want with your time
anything you would like to say to my
lovely audience I am thrilled beyond
thrilled to be sitting here with Charlie
I'm not gonna dye my hair I don't know I
know I've said plenty of dumb because
they've ended up on the internet so just
be yet another thanks you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool so let's play a triple fail I
am gonna give you two suppose in fact
one of them will be true one of them
will be false it's up to you to click on
which one you think is the true fact or
else you will fatal number one whenever
a character in Toy Story blinks they
blink one eye at a time or number two
pick some films usually have around 7000
storyboards but wall-e because of its
complexity at 25,000 storyboards click
on one of these it's your job to click
on one of these it's either that one or
that one one of the two doobly-doo click
on one of them it's your job or you
don't have to if you don't want to but I
would like it if you did so I can stop
doing this doot-doot-doot click on one
of these dooba dooba do click one of
these